at what point in this journey did you
begin your production company
early on so once you sort of um
started you know the short films and
things like that i just
um my first short film was called
balloons go pop and then so i started
go pop films and um and that
started with the short films that i was
i was doing
and and then when we embarked on making
the feature film
uh we partner up with red productions on
and which is uh based in fort worth
texas and santa monica
and then um and then recently
we um started a commercial division
of uh rep representing different um
commercial directors
for for that so it was a slope process
um it was me all the way back then
and then just learning the business of
things and then
going hey you know if this person could
start
um a production company what's stopping
me from
legal paperwork you know things like
that so
so um that's that's exactly um
the path and i wanted to have something
i i could
um control as a business
can you talk about the process for
starting your business like step by step
what did you do
yeah so um it depends on you know
obviously if you start out first if if
it's just by yourself for people out
there
since not knowing you could you could be
a sole proprietor
so you don't have to you know you could
you don't have to
um start an llc
um we i eventually moved into
on gopot films as an llc
to gain the protection of that but with
that in mind
there's different fees uh involved
um state fees different you know taxes
and things like that um involved
so being like a producer versus like a
director or anyone like that
you know you
you have to sort of
be on top of all the legal
regulations the taxes and things like
that um
so when you start like your production
company whether it's a commercial
production company
um you start charging people on fees
um producing video content editing
and then and then you would charge that
then that'll be your revenue for the
year
and you minus all your expenses and then
you know
um at first i was doing like
all my taxes and things and then you
want to find a good
good accountant afterward it gets a
little bit hairy and things like that
and for those who are maybe starting a
film or a movie or feature film
we we had our films called all roads to
perrla
prior to that it was called sleeping
plastic we started a
sleeping plastic llc so the film itself
is its own entity um
separate from go pop films you know so
each film that
you'll make will have its own um
you know life so that's
sort of the progression of that of that
so i had this idea
that wow okay i'll have go pop films and
we'll do um films we'd do short films
and hopefully get into future films
and then i had this other great idea
because
i was trying to get into the commercial
world
of of of directing and video and then
instead of being in other people's
rosters
oh why don't i create my own um
commercial vision
and and collect
talent that i think are that
have a great voice and and and
professional
and could deliver um you know video
content and and and start started that
way so
i liked the producing part after i did
after i was
um produced the first feature film i was
like whoa
this is a pain in the butt but you learn
so much then you almost like
don't wanna for me i always like i like
producing
i think it became um it was fun
you know to put things together to help
a director help their vision come
alive with this with the constraint of
the budget
and that's that's that's the key you
know i was lucky to work with
red sanders and derek derek brown from
red productions when i first met them
they're like man how can we um
help you make your your vision and i was
like that
wow everyone else they were very honest
about that
and i remember derek um brown was like
that's part about being a good producer
is helping
the director um
get their vision out there come alive
and and
that's what i would like to do with
other filmmakers is help
them get their you know vision alive so
i love that aspect too
you know did you form the llc's yourself
or did you
use a lawyer or some type of legal
service oh legalizing
legal right there is it's um
pretty pretty easy that's that's what we
did for um go pop films yeah
and and then for the the movie as well
no uh for the movie
um red uh productions
of red entertainment and us we had a um
a lawyer
on because the the
i believe our um because we were
shooting in in
oklahoma and texas so we we had you know
a couple different um
uh kind of more um
uh kind of the more more uh complicated
things so we read red had a lawyer that
he always used
um for their their films so we went with
the same one
for because this this would would have
been their seventh film that they've
done
our film so um uh i was going with them
you know it's like it's
i think that's the funniest of the thing
i've learned
is this whole like industry
i've learned is it's about leverage it's
kind of interesting when i was starting
and and trying to push the script around
and they would go
oh you haven't done a feature film
before it's all
you have this is all about execution you
got could you execute this can you do
that
and then then once once
i was fortunate enough to work with red
productions who've done all these great
films before
i you know i was able to work with
that's like playing with someone who is
better at you
in tennis so you get better so those
these last three or four years working
with all these people was was a dream
because
it was i was still absorbing and
learning
on what this industry is about what's
producing about what's the legal work
what's how do you get things done
um you know it's like
like being a director is is different
being a producer you can't have a
sustainable career if
you don't make your investors money back
being a director
even though you the movie might not be
financial success
but it might you know garner some
accolades your career could keep
keep going so the producer's role is
really um it's brutal you have it's
it's strictly business you know you
gotta um
you gotta make your investors money back
and that's a different
different mindset you know um so
i love both all the challenges of it
what's one thing that was a surprise
whether it was the paperwork
forming the llc talking to the attorney
that you were so glad that you'll always
take with you
moving forward that maybe was a surprise
whether it was
you didn't know when the fees for the
llc were do
like just different things which i know
those things
when you get an irs uh letter coming at
you that's a big surrounding
yeah yeah well it took out the bone down
yeah yeah so you don't want to mess with
the
irs so the surprises um there's always
a surprise you know the surprises uh
um if you get used to um
learning if you get used to your
mistakes and but don't repeat them
i think that's that's great because no
i mean you could go to all these great
schools like producing and or
business schools and learn a lot of
things but it's something not being like
trenches and go oh my gosh that
eight hundred dollar fee it's what's the
october 15th we it has to be in you know
it's like so
um oh you know did the actors do we get
the
the the agreements done you know what uh
the the agents come and talk and did we
get this sign
so the surprise is
get everything in writing sign
everything
um it's all business you know there's a
reason that's why it's called
the movie business not the movie let's
make
vans art you know it's it's it's a
it's uh you got to enjoy that aspect of
it
but if you love storytelling and you
know how to
um kind of play the play and learn the
rules
of the movie business and and then um
i think you'll you know enjoy it
great yeah yeah no no one wants to get a
letter
yeah no one wants to get a letter from
an irs and then you know
and that's one of those things where you
want to call right away yeah
even if you're on hold for two hours
yeah that's why yes
it's all those things and there's fees
and they and they'll just
keep keep going so um
you know the things i get i guess the
thing that um
surprised me probably is uh
once you think you have it all sent and
done there's always something else
you know oh there's like i thought we
did that
then the deliverables didn't get deliver
that or then wasn't that signed or
what do you mean you know it's like you
have to be you have to be
very thorough yeah when you formed your
production company did you take out a
loan to purchase
equipment yeah um so
when we uh when i first started before
on the equipment was
on just you know like your dslr
on cameras your your um
your uh your sound lights and everything
so it was it was credit cards you know
those credit cards um i did i didn't do
a pr
uh like a personal loan and this was
like
10 years ago 10 plus years ago yeah and
then
um but then as you get
more involved and you know what what's
going when we've
switched from sole proprietor to llc
that's when we you know you you had
investors in
in the company so then and then you had
capital and equity and things like that
that you have to um sort out
but i i was just like any other
small um business owner
with it with their dream and and
credit cards that's it's a rough rough
game i
i had a friend who who um
uh opened up this bar with eight
nine credit cards and it became um
the most popular bar like it won like
most popular bar
in the world like um
like a couple years back it's called
employees only
and uh and i remember way back when
and they had this dream and they did it
it's not
a good uh start but it was the only
start i had because i wanted
i wanted to do it you know um and i
i didn't have like i didn't go to the
bank and go hey
i need fifty thousand dollars to start
this i didn't go to small business
loans um i kept my overhead low
that's the thing so then once you have
start having jobs
um you know then you could pay things
out so the key is keeping your overhead
low
which means you know don't be straddled
with
with um rent payroll
um if i would spend on anything i didn't
spend that much on
on equipment i spent more on marketing
um
i would do that because uh so
that's what i would would we still do
you know yeah don't be late with that
credit card payment because
oh yeah 29 late fee then go yeah
and then you get a call eight o'clock on
a sunday morning
yeah and then i'm gonna speak to van
please yeah exactly
you know yeah and yeah you asked that
question like is it
was it the right path you know um
it's the path of an entrepreneur i think
there's
there's an inherent stress that no one
sort of talks about all the time
of whether whether it's
whether it's your credit cards whether
it's your investors where it's
getting distribution i'm going to get in
this film festival i'm going to get that
after all years of all this you've come
comfortable being uncomfortable so
you you start to also become smarter and
become a better business person i always
love it when i see
signs that says been in business since
1984 i've been in c
it's like that's awesome you know how
hard is this maintain any business
there's a stretch amount of time whether
you're shining shoes or this
it's the same thing with them you know
like getting a movie
so i kind of
had to tell myself uh to take a chill
pill
and take one day at a time or i'm going
to get an
ulcer and a goiter if i keep worrying
about the are we going to get in this
film festival i'm going to do that are
we going to do this it's like
then you sit back it's like okay
if you do then what if you do then what
it all comes to back down to why did you
start 10 years ago
i love writing i love doing this so
i always wanted to try to tell myself to
not make something i love
an albatross you know so i have to
really remind myself of that every time
you know so okay
is this what you want to do okay
get better don't you know don't be don't
become cynical
um things like that
you